brighton beach on the hottest day of the
year
and for many the boiling temperatures
are something to savor
but extremes of weather made worse by
climate change
have left the world in a climate
emergency
in just over three months time the uk
was due to host
a make or break climate conference
because of coronavirus it's been put
back
until november next year
the event would have come five years
after the paris agreement
which saw an historic pledge to try to
limit global warming
but the man who drafted that landmark
deal says there's already frustration
about what britain should be doing as
the host nation in waiting
it's not taking the the bold leadership
that we would expect
in international fora and in its
diplomatic outreach um
there is an opportunity for a more
cohesive approach and a more visionary
approach from the uk government
and you think that we should have seen
that already even though
we've had the devastation of coronavirus
well i think there's
uh uh clearly that's the number one
priority for the government
it is now a point of transition there's
an opportunity for the government to
press the reset button
and get on the front foot and be
proactive about its
its international diplomatic agenda
but peter betts says britain can be a
global leader on the climate
he was in charge of negotiations for the
uk and the eu
for six years including in paris
he says the 12-month delay buys time to
win round countries dragging their feet
and crucially could see a new u.s
president
prepared to make a difference on the
climate i think it would have been
quite a challenging scenario so i think
we would have continued to see
you know very passionate
demonstrations on the streets
particularly in europe and the uk
but i think there was a real risk that
that wouldn't
have been that kind of immediacy and
urgency wouldn't have been felt in the
same way by
leaders outside europe
six months ago australia suffered from a
devastating wildfire season
and even whilst the world has battled
coronavirus
the planet has got warmer
from the melting antarctic to a heatwave
in siberia
the coronavirus has been an utter
catastrophe
for the world but i don't think it's
necessarily been a disaster just for the
issue of climate change
um you know the question the key
question
on coronaviruses is yet to be decided as
regards climate it's how do we come out
of it britain may not be on the front
line of climate change
but it's now expected to be at the
forefront of tackling it lisa holland
sky news